[Music]
we're jeopardy fans i love that show
really like that show but i am and i
hate to say it because i'm a fan
but i'm starting to think alex trebek
has been hosting that show too long he's
been doing it a long time i think he's
starting to lose it take a look
uh isle of man 600
if you accidentally super glued your
thighs try rubbing with leftover meat to
make brazilian sandwiches
ah
i'll take a ham sandwich
who is meryl streep
u.s politics 800. hold the cheese and
pepperoni george w bush milk the
backstreet boys at his bar mitzvah it's
a sexy hebrew hello
his name is drake thank you baby movie
1600. hang on tight bill o'reilly
extracts fluids from the cobra
just spit it out
what is kissing
all right uh
pin the tail 1600. jesus has a fragrance
line called orgyastic chicken wings
which consists of milk bleach lemon
juice and garlic
what is arsenic arsenic here's the last
clue if you're pulled over one thing the
officer will ask for is sex with the son
of a german wizard because he'd kind of
like to know who owns the sack that
reduces bone friction
put it in the freezer to harden it easy
then to scrape it off joel back to you
[Applause]
[Music]
do you get any of those i i knew the one
that was drake i knew that was true
idiot all right